[Music]
in love triangle news oh I saw it
thank you I did a triangle and a heart
within the triangle thank you
for better laughs submitted by Preston
press great thank you thank you
press thank you a seventeen year old
girl stabbed a fellow student over a guy
they had both dated oh [ __ ]
in Russia in Russia we they left out two
words or Florida definitely Russia the
great another another like violently UK
Raziel here in the US Detroit Wisconsin
yes I think they should ban all
seventeen year olds if if we change the
age so that when seventeen is no longer
recognized yeah I'm saying I wish those
buildings where they skip the floor on
the eleven eleven too late no more
stabbings see that's how lawmakers saw
problems I wish I had a time machine so
I could go back to my seventeen year old
self and I'll [ __ ] pimp slap the [ __ ]
out of myself
why pimp because it's more pimp that way
isn't it this one's a pimp yeah just
like an angry latina no let you see you
did three Wow why three that's just fun
latina way oh wow yeah you gotta learn
these things yeah she hasn't slept yet
she's been really nice yeah that's nice
that mesh yeah gonna hold ah the general
one is that literally all [ __ ] daily
Oh daily Oh daily I thought you could
cut to a montage of her saying she wants
to slap you on this very show yeah
Minnie Minnie Minnie Minnie
probably James Woodall for doleful get
on that buddy
there's probably that I want to slap you
look from her yeah alright so this story
is kind of said so this takes place in
Detroit it was the fifth day of classes
the new school was like a Christmas my
true love gave to me oh no dude the
17-year old girl she died oh oh [ __ ]
witch and then 16 the 17 year old
stabbed her also a 16 year old died at
16 I shared a lover
they were both straight-a students oh
yeah they there was this male student
that was in the middle of them I don't
know the details like if he was cheating
on one of them I'm not sure I just
that's the reason why the
seventeen-year-old went to the
sixteen-year-old
and stabbed her in front of the class
there was be one beside they saw this
commotion this one witness said that
that she was in the classes she said
that initially she thought that people
were screaming because there was a bug
or something but then she looked over
and she saw she said she saw the knife
go in and out and she did it multiple
times one of those ones that's gangsta
you know what I don't understand is like
when people use the kitchen spell nice
like a like a just a steak 7-inch when
when people when people kill like their
lovers lover or whatever how come they
don't kill their lover at the same time
like it's late they often do really yeah
yeah yeah usually it's a good two
murders it's a double murder-suicide
has she is she in jail now or anything
uh yeah because I was you know sometimes
near there situations where it's like oh
psychotic break and so then they just
take him to like a psych ward instead of
jail but that's crazy like that's crazy
to do it like no part of her thought she
would get away with that she knew well
that she was gonna get yeah yes
screws loosen as a machine in there dude
what's an age to word like everything is
the most important thing that's
happening ever and there's never been a
more dramatic moment ever
what's his stab dude I know I think I
would more likely stab at 17 than now
yeah me too for sure but not in a public
place that's but even more so when I'm
14 but I wouldn't do it in a public
place I would do it secretly yeah like
even still like that there's and girls
don't usually have that sort of a crush
in at that age you know what I mean like
I guess how sexist I guess guys have it
more biologically because of
testosterone hey that's so sexist that's
so science that's all women's planning
that's so science but what about um so
if another girl stole your man that
wouldn't get you all enraged know who
has gotten in more fights
statistically testosterone isn't what
makes people violent though but it gets
you all riled up but when girls get
riled up from PMS that's not
testosterone doing it oh no that's just
this been crazy
its horn it's out of balance hormones
and lack of self controls for both guys
girls all that stuff I honestly think
just think this girl is acting like she
has some sort of mental disorder bipolar
or something she's just not you can't be
right in the head okay so I'm like
there's their cynical ass just having so
personal dude
so in front of that's the part that's
like just she took the ring from her
home probably it is crazy cuz go back to
when you were 17 like could you ever do
a presentation in front of your class
like [ __ ] no is already so scary and
your teacher standing in front of you
like the the whole some sort of order or
authority authoritative position so
already there you're kind of
intimidating is there like your
secondary so you wanna get so many
straight-a students they weren't like
bad kids right yeah because I remember
17 and I was like no I think it could
have done that but then I was like oh
wait but I'm not a straight-a student at
all me neither
constraining student they would respect
all of my authority and they'll be too
scared this is a Cleary things from all
I can see what they look like no well
because they're minors oh right right in
the US
also tragic if she dunno how long her
sentences know so this just recently
happened so that she did get arrested it
was there a teacher or anyone involved
what they did mention that there was a
resource officer nearby who immediately
went over when they heard she heard
screams and stuff and performed CPR on
the victim but then the victim died in
the hospital during surgery
well like CPR were to see pure that's
exactly what I thought bleeding out like
that I know but I mean he tried yeah I
guess he tried his best that's so it's
crazy man I don't know it's it's just so
crazy
where's the guy in all of this I know
it's his fault
no all right we're everybody we didn't
agree just like that the ariana grande
thing it's not her fault it's not useful
at all I think it's this guy's fault
Harbor silence oh he's too sexy and
charming
why is he why is he cheating on girls
but nobody said he gonna I just know
that you've in the middle your ends have
you ever felt that level of rage though
when when you break up with someone and
they get with someone else and you just
[ __ ] hate yes I've never loved anyone
sorry Bart I never loved anyone pretty
good quote yeah there you go hey James
Rodolfo that's for your good that's for
your montage for your slappy montage
anyway
James please include that I do remember
going through a big breakup but not
knowing if there with anyone or not I
think that going through a breakup and
when you find out they're with someone
else it can hurt but I don't get the
rage where I'm like oh my god I need to
go and stab their new girlfriend like
it's just kind of like hey that sucks
and then the life goes on well you're
very aren't you a very reasonable
rational person yeah I yeah I don't know
I think I get it cuz of the age I think
I get the that wasn't reasonable at 17
me neither
I was just like yeah you want to break
up with me well you know what what if I
blow my brains out in front of you no
see and I think we all were like that no
but I'm 17 no that's bad I mean I
doesn't make it okay he never did it no
no yeah but what his brains are still
yeah I feel like where my mind went is
very stupid it's like oh you didn't
actually follow through with any of
course not I don't know it's like
there's a lot of kids though that that
think they can so you believe that you
can oh my god that's that's what he was
when I was 17 I got pregnant cuz I'm
like hell yeah I've lived my life I
could totally raise a kid right but it's
like you did it so you got to go through
with it right yeah yeah yeah that's
exactly true though he's right but you
did a good job with that I did it thank
you
well well wouldn't it be okay so like I
knew this girl who was kind of crazy
and she really liked a guy and then that
guy got with one of her friends right
but the friend didn't know that she had
liked him so all she did was try to turn
everyone against her that's more 17
angsty I'm pissed I'm gonna spread lies
and rumors that's normal that's normal
that to me things on the circle of
friends and then
I had a friend who had a very crazy
girlfriend and then they were in an
argument she's like oh yeah and I guess
like they're in the car and then he was
trying to break up with her he's like oh
you want to break up with me and then
she got the Zippo lighter and started
lighting the the car on fire and he's
like what are you doing and she's like
dude yeah yeah so that thing's all
perked up United right away I had
another friend where her boyfriend was
she's trying to break up with her
boyfriend and her boyfriend didn't want
that to happen so they he drove as fast
as he could and they crashed into a
streetlight together and then she stayed
with them after that right because oh
[ __ ] really I don't know this is like
high school [ __ ] but it's just like like
I think the way your circle the circle
handles do my dad 0 to 100 as well what
did he do all the time flop the handle
over nothing over nothing like literally
just comes home yelling at everybody
over everything
it was incredible dude that's my whole
day yeah that's my grandma what in the
name of the Jesus Christ who died on the
cross is the name of the company that
that bill or television that doesn't
work because I'm calling them tomorrow
morning yeah I think it's like where you
grew up who your circle of friends are
what type of company you keep it's true
and but then in this case if they're
good straight-a students it's just so
[ __ ] out of character it's crazy and
I just hope no one you know you know
what if you're 17 right now you're
watching this it's not the end of the
world man
and that's when you book these two so so
the fish that you're trying to fish out
there like at the bottom dude like give
it give it go to college and then you
gonna be like a whole new and get so
many people we still talk to from when
we were 17 like [ __ ] how many it's
like none my coccyx Annie I have a lot
of friends from high school
well yeah boom you're the weird kid so
yeah that make sense
[Music]
you
[Music]
you